من اسبانيا الى وقفتنا الاولى مع مراسلنا
في فرنسا ليث بزاري والحديث عن جدل واسع
في فرنسا بعد اعتراف وزاره الداخليه
بطلبها قوائم تغيب الطلاب المسلمين في عيد
الفطر هذا الامر اثاره غضبا واسعا في
المنظمات المناهضه
للعنصريه من هناك ليث
بزهري سينضم الينا يا هلا اول شيء الحمد
لله على السلامه من الوراء والحمد لله على
السلامه
الله يخليك شكرا الله يسلمك صباح الخير
لكما راويه وعادل شكرا شكرا خلينا نعرف
التفاصيل يا ليث قبل ما بضعه ايام يا
راويه وعادل
نعم
لنعد الى بضعه ايام الى الوراء وتحديدا
اجازه عيد الفطر التي صادفت في فرنسا يوم
الجمعه 21 من ابريل نيسان من هذا العام
تفاجا مديره بعض المدارس في منطقه تولوز
جنوب فرنسا بتلقي ايميلات تنص على الطلب
من كل مدير مدرسه احصاء عدد الطلاب
الغائبين عن المدرسه يوم عيد الفطر
الرساله الالكترونيه تلقتها حوالي 100
مؤسسه تعليميه من روضه اطفال الى المدارس
الثانويه طلب اثار استياء القطاع التربوي
في فرنسا مصطفى فورار رئيس الاكاديميه
الاقليميه في منطقه تولوز صرح قائلا لا
نقوم باي حال من الاحوال باجراء تحقيقات
من هذا النوع واضاف بمجرد ان ان ابلغنا
رؤساء المؤسسات ومديرون مدارس بهذا الطلب
اصدرت تعليمات واضحه بعدم الاستجابه بها
او لهذا الطلب فهذا خرق في القانون
الفرنسي وشدد مصطفى على ان اجهزه
المخابرات الاقليميه الفرنسيه مرت عبر
الشرطه وكانت رسالتهم او الرسائل مصابه
بشكل سيء اثار هذا الموضوع طبعا الذي كشفت
عنه صحيفه فرنسيه محليه تمديدا من جانب
نقابات التعليم واستنكرته الجمعيات
المناهضه للعنصريه وردا على الجدل المثار
اكدت كاتبه الدوله المكلفه بالمواطنه
سونيا باكاس في بيان لها على عكس ما قيل
في الايام الاخيره من الواضح ان وزاره
الداخليه والاقاليم ما وراء البحار لا
تمارس اي تسجيل للطلاب حسب عقيدتهم في
المقابل اكدت ان وزاره الداخليه تدرس
بانتظام تاثير بعض الاعياد الدينيه على
اداء الخدمات
الاكاديمي ولكن في مشكله اخرى على ما يبدو
اوجاد الاخر في قلق عند السياح كمان في
فرنسا شو تفاصيله
نعم هي قصه
سياحيه صيفيه راويه فمنذ عوده الحياه بعد
كورونا حثت السلطات الفرنسيه الفرنسيون ان
تكون اجازاتهم داخليه يعني محليه لعدم
لدعم الاقتصاد الفرنسي الذي عان الكثير من
الوباء ما دفع الكثير منهم الى قصد
المناطق السياحيه او الجبليه لكن صيف هذا
العام يتحفظ الكثير منهم على قصد تلك
المناطق خصوصا جنوب فرنسا نظرا طبعا
للكوارث الطبيعيه التي حدثت العام الماضي
في نفس الفتره من السنه اي الحرائق
والجفاف اذ اتهمت النيران الاف الهكتارات
من الغابات وتم اجداء المصطافون من اماكن
قضاء اجازاتهم الصيفيه والغاء اجازاتهم
والعوده الى منازلهم اليوم قبل اقل من
شهرين من الاجازه الصيفيه في فرنسا بدات
حجوزات السفر الى خارج اوروبا ترتفع بنسبه
15% عن العام الماضي وهناك اقبال كبير على
البحيرات والمناطق الجبليه التي لا يقصدها
الكثير يلا ان شاء الله ان شاء الله يا
ليث يعني بالتاكيد انت ايضا تصح وتعود الى
ممارسه نشاطاتك ايضا في فرنسا
ما بس ما راح يطلع هاي
كسول كسول لا كسول شكرا لك يعطيك العافيه
المزيد لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على
اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات